[Music]
all right so after ghosting ignoring
speaker McCarthy for nearly a hundred
days Biden finally gave in and met with
McCarthy about the debt ceiling now in
just 22 days America will default on its
stat unless the pair can reach an
agreement but Joe still refusing to
negotiate take a look
97 days ago I was right here after
meeting with the president
on February 1st I came down to see him
saying let's work together in
responsible sensible way
that we can lift the debt ceiling
and find a way that we can curve this
increasing debt that is affecting every
American family with inflation nothing
has changed since then the only thing
that has changed is the house has raised
the debt ceiling and passed the bill
that's why we had a meeting today
everybody in this meeting reiterated the
positions they were at I didn't see any
new movement I don't want to play
politics with this I think this is too
important that's why three months ago I
came to the president
can't we find a way I know we're both
going to have to give and take that's
the way the founders have created our
government a house a senate the
executive branch so let's sit down
together find places we can agree upon
and get this done
now the speaker is right to Biden's
surprise House Republicans did pass a
bill that both raises the debt ceiling
and cut spending so now Biden can just
sign the bill or he will need to
negotiate and find a resolution and
according to Joe Biden from 2011 he says
that's the right thing to do but
remember from the beginning he said no
negotiating take a look
how do you explain the fact that grown
men and women are unwilling to budge up
till now and still some of them are
still unwilling to budge by taking an
absolute position my way or no way I
predict to you that a lot of those new
members who came here with my way or the
highway they'll either be on the highway
or they'll learn that they have to have
compromise
all right that was Biden then and this
is by now now he's my way of the highway
take a look and I've settled all along
let's discuss what we need to cut what
we need to protect what new Revenue we
can raise and how to lower the deficit
to put our fiscal house in order
but in the meantime in the meantime we
need to take the threat of default off
the table the first you didn't listen
either so why should I even answer the
question I we cut the deficit by 160
billion dollars billion b-i-l-l-i-o-n
dollars on the Medicare deal
all right now unfortunately Biden and
his friends want a free pass but Senate
Republicans they're standing firm at
least 43 of them now have signed on to a
letter refusing to vote for a debt
ceiling increase without serious
spending and budget reform my next guest
also says he would not support the
so-called clean debt ceiling increase
unless it has fiscal responsibility
measures in it Louisiana Senator John
Kennedy is with us right now so he had
97 days to meet with McCarthy 97 days to
negotiate finally the house raises the
debt ceiling they return spending to
2022 levels they reduce Baseline
budgeting to only a one percent increase
annually to keep the budget in line they
also have Provisions in there for
example for energy to me it's a great
Bill uh you would be the 44th Senator
that will not go along with cloture it
looks like it's that bill or no bill
because I don't think Kevin McCarthy is
going to be able to changes caucus
well there's only one plan on the table
and that's speaker McCarthy's and
majority leader scalesis look Shawna I
confess I don't understand Preston Biden
there are there that's one of the
greatest Mysteries of the universe
Senator if you could I I would be
listening for hours
well there there are times that I think
President Biden is being advised
by the marketing team at Budweiser
um his his poll numbers are on a Journey
to the Center of the Earth
and it's no mystery why because of the
president's policies the American people
feel chewed up spit out and stepped on
uh inflation crime the Border
Afghanistan the forfeiture of America's
energy Independence because of his
coveted policies our kids have
experienced the largest learning loss in
modern history
I mean how many roads must a man walk
down until he knows he is lost
um now speaker McCarthy has given the
president an extraordinary opportunity
to demonstrate leadership
and if the president doesn't take it
and he causes America to default
on its debt the presence of smoked
turkey
and I don't understand why he doesn't
understand that today they met finally
and what did the president do he said
well I'm going to turn it over to my
staff I don't I don't like your bill
that you even though it's only playing
on the table I'm going to turn it over
to my staff and we may meet again
are you kidding me
I mean the
fair or not according to the polls
most Americans think the president is
older than the Adirondack Mountains and
that and that that he's not fit to be
president
uh what the President should have done
what I would have done in that situation
is say Okay speaker I appreciate you
coming by uh clear your calendar we're
going to meet four hours tomorrow four
hours the next day four hours the next
day four hours the next day until we
hammer out an agreement that raises the
debt ceiling and reduces the rate of
growth of spending and debt accumulation
to get inflation under control
and demonstrate leadership
do you believe that Mitch McConnell will
stand strong with the 43 other
Republican Senators and by the way I
think Joe manchin is on board with this
as well uh will he stay firm in
insisting on the type of fiscal
restraints that the house bill put in
place
well you'll have to ask ask Mitch that
question Sean I I just know that um
um
that we are we we are trading in our
future for today
with all the spending the spending and
debt accumulation is the the underlying
reason we have inflation
and no one I don't want to default on
America's debt
but but this is an extraordinary
opportunity for us to to solve two
problems at once and I just don't
understand why President Biden will not
see it like that because I've seen it if
he right now McCarthy's plan is the only
plan on the table and if the president
rejects it and causes America to default
on its debt he is a smoked turkey and
America is hurt badly there will be only
one person in the end to blame and
that's Joe Biden he was betting the last
97 days that Republicans with this small
majority would not pass a bill well they
did and now he's got to deal with it and
thankfully and I'll say this to you and
and your 43 other colleagues uh you're
holding firm in the Senate that will
enable what is a fiscally responsible
Bill to be passed one that also raises
the debt ceiling so the country doesn't
default
well I'm very proud of speaker McCarthy
I'm very proud of majority leaders
police I like the bill
um and and I'm hoping that the I
shouldn't say that I'm hoping to say the
president will I'm hoping that the
president will will will will will agree
that that it's something worth pursuing
let me be polite and end this with
politeness you know I wish I didn't stop
you uh whenever you want to say
something just let it out on the show
Senator we appreciate it everybody needs
everybody needs to take their meds and
and act like an adult for a change we're
talking about Washington I'm not sure if
that's possible I don't know I don't
know if there's enough medication
available in the country to to help out
that swamp anyway Senator great to see
you thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else